We were talking last time
about the mysterious episode
by the [inaudible] River,
uh,
when Jacob undergoes a change name.
And I mentioned the fact
that in the biblical view,
the name of something somehow encapsulates
its very essence and knowing the name
of something gives one power
or control over that thing.
Many commentators have observed that the
change in name accompanies a change in
character, a change of essence
in Israel. So some have a noted,
one scholar in particular is noted that
the struggle with the angel is the final
purging of the unsavory qualities of
character that Marc Jacobs past career.
And although Jacob appears to
be something of an anti hero,
he actually literally limps into
the promised land alone. Uh,
Jacob is a new and honest man and we
see this immediately in his reunion with
Esau. He greets his former rival
and enemy with these words.
This is in Genesis 33 verses 10 to 11.
If you would do me this
favor except for me,
this gift for to see your face is like
seeing the face of God and you have
received me favorably.
Please accept my present,
which has been brought to you for
God has favored me and I have plenty.
And when he urged him,
he accepted with Jacob,
who is now Israel.
God's seems perhaps to finally have found
the working relationship with humans
that he has been seeking
since their creation.
God learned immediately after creating
this unique being that he will exercise
his free will against God. God's seed, uh,
saw that he had to limit the lifespan
of humans or risk creating an enemy that
was nearly equal to him.
So he casts the humans out of the garden,
blocks access to the tree of life.
But humans continue their violence
and evil ways. And in desperation,
God wipes him out and starts again.
And this second creation proves
to be not much better. Um, gut.
They forget God, they turn to idolatry.
God has promised at this point, however,
not to destroy all humankind again.
So he experiments with a single
individual of faith and Abraham's faith
withstands many a trial.
He is obedient to God in a way that no
one has been up to this point in the
narrative.
But perhaps ultimately the model
of blind obedience is rejected too.
When Abraham prepares to
slaughter his own son,
perhaps God sees that blind faith
can be as destructive and evil as
disobedience. So God relinquishes
his demand for blind obedience,
he stops Abraham himself.
The only relationship that will work
with humans is perhaps one in which there
is a balance between unchecked
independence and blind
obedience and God seems to
find that relationship with Jacob and
the metaphor for that relationship is a
metaphor of struggle or wrestling.
Remember East by all means,
one who wrestles,
who struggles with God,
God and humans lock in
an eternal struggle,
neither prevailing yet both
forever changed by their
encounter with one another.
Now, the rest of genesis relates the
story of Joseph and his brothers,
the 12 the 12 sons of Jacob.
It's one of the most magnificent
psychological dramas in the Bible.
The stories intensely human.
We don't have a lot of supernatural
interference in this story if focuses very
much on the family relationships
and the jealousies,
very little reference
to a divine perspective.
It's like a little novella and scholars
are divided over the authenticity of the
Egyptian elements. In the story, you
will read radically diverse things,
some point to the presence of Egyptian
names and customs and religious beliefs
and laws as a sign of, of,
uh, some historical memory,
uh, being preserved in this,
in these stories. Others point to
all the problems, the anachronisms,
the general lack of
specificity that's assigned,
that these are composed quite late.
The Art of dream interpretation plays
a very important role in this story.
And dream interpretation
was a developed science,
particularly in Egypt and the
other parts of Mesopotamia,
but the Egyptians were known in the
ancient world is dream interpreters.
Joseph is also known for his
ability to interpret dreams,
but the biblical narrator, the
monetizing biblical narrator, uh,
is very concerned to describe him as
reporting what God reveals to him rather
than relying on some kind of occult
science of interpretation. Now,
Joseph's brothers are jealous
of Jacob's partiality to Joseph,
and they conspire to be rid of him.
But at the last moment,
his brother Judah convinces the
brothers that if instead of killing him,
they sell him, they can profit
a little for their troubles.
So Joseph is sold,
ultimately ends up in the household of
Pharaoh in Egypt and his adventures there
prove his a meritorious character.
So he rises to a position of great
power when he correctly interprets, um,
some dreams regarding an impending famine.
And with Joseph as the governor of the
country in control of the grain supply,
Egypt's successfully weathers seven
years of famine. Now this famine,
which strikes Kanan as well,
drives Joseph's brothers
to Egypt in search of food.
And Joseph doesn't reveal himself to
his brothers. He puts them to the test.
He wants to know if they are the same
men who so callously broke their father's
heart by selling Joseph his
father's favorite so many years ago.
And in the climactic moment in the story,
Joseph demands that his frightened
brothers leave Benjamin,
the other son of Rachel,
the other son of the beloved wife,
leave Benjamin as a pledge in Egypt.
And Joseph knows that it would
decimate his father Jacob to lose.
Rachel's only remaining son,
but he's testing his brothers to see
whether they have reforms since the day
that they sold him into slavery.
And indeed Judah,
the one who had figured so prominently
in the sale of Joseph that had crushed
his father Judah steps and offers
himself instead of Benjamin.
He says it would, it would kill my father
now to lose Benjamin. Um, the, the last,
uh,
son of his beloved wife Rachel.
So the brothers having proven their
new integrity, uh, Joseph weeps,
he reveals his identity in a very moving
scene and ultimately the family has
relocated to and reunited in Egypt where
they live peacefully and prosperously
for some generations.
That's the basic outline of the
story of Joseph and his brothers.
But one of the important themes of
these stories is the theme of God's
Providence. The writer wants
to represent Jacob's sons.
They're petty jealousies there.
Murderous conspiracy, Joseph himself,
all as the unwitting instruments
of a larger divine plan.
In effect, Joseph says to his brothers
in Genesis 50 verse 20, as for you,
you meant evil against me,
but God meant it for good to bring it
about that many people should be kept
alive as they are today.
So Joseph's betrayal by his brothers,
his descent into Egypt,
uh,
set the stage not only for the
reformation of his brothers characters,
which is an important part of the story,
but for the descent of all of the
Israelites into Egypt so as to survive
widespread famine. So yet another
threat to the promise is overcome.
Threat of famine is overcome by the
relocation to Egypt. Significantly,
God says to Jacob in genesis 46,
verse four,
I myself will go down with you to Egypt
and I myself will also bring you back.
So in short, there seems
to be a plan afoot, right?
The writer wants to represent God.
God's going down there and he will,
he will bring them back.
Israel's descent to Egypt sets the stage
for the rise of a pharaoh who the texts
says didn't know Joseph and
all that he had done for Egypt.
And this new pharaoh will
enslave the Israelites,
and so embitter their lives that
they're cry will rise up to heaven.
The same cry from the
generation of the flood,
the same cry from Sodom and Gomorrah,
and thus begins the book of Exodus,
which will lead us from Egypt to Sinai.
Most of the narrative account
in Genesis 12 to 50 is uh,
with the exception of the
Joseph story actually,
but most of genesis 12 through 50 is
assigned by scholars to the j source.
And certain themes emerge
in the j narrative.
The first is that while God's promise
is sure the manner and the timing of its
fulfillment is quite unpredictable,
the land never belongs to the
Patriarchs to whom it was promised their
descendants will take possession of it,
but only after tremendous
struggle in other ways,
God's methods are curious.
Why does he go against the traditional
ancient near eastern practice of
primogenitor primogenitor
inheritance by the firstborn,
he chooses Jacob a liar and a cheat in
his early life over the elder east saw.
Why does he choose young Joseph
who's an arrogant, spoiled Brat?
He provokes his brother's with
his delusions of grandeur.
Compare the law of primogenitor that's
listed in Deuteronomy 21 verses 15 to 17
if a man has two wives,
one loved and one the other unloved and
both the loved and the unloved have born
him sons. But the first born
is the son of the unloved one.
When he wills his property to his sons,
he may not treat as first born the son
of the loved one in disregard of the son
of the unloved one who is older.
And yet isn't this what happens to you?
Should mail, is it? This
is what happens to Esau,
is this what happens to all of Joseph's
brothers who are born before him?
And there's no explanation
in the text yet,
despite the false starts and the trials
and the years of famine and the and the
childlessness and the infertility,
the seed of Abraham survives
and the promise is reiterated,
I will go down myself with you to Egypt
and I myself will also bring you back.
So ultimately the j source would appear
to assert God does control history all
tends toward his purpose.
And the book of Exodus is really the
sequel then to the book of Genesis. Um,
despite God's promise of land and
blessing, things don't look so good.
At the end of Genesis, the book closes
with the Israelites residing in Egypt.
They've managed to procure a no more
than a burial plot in the promised land.
Even God has left his land descending
with the Israelites into Egypt.
So the promises and their
fulfillment seem quite remote.
The book of Exodus will relate the
beginning of the process by which the
promises will be fulfilled just charted
the structure very briefly for you so
you can get your footing
in the book of Exodus.
The first 15 chapters tell
the story of Israel in Egypt,
the rise of a new pharaoh
who didn't know Joseph,
the oppression of the Israelites,
their enslavement in a state labor force,
the killing of all firstborn Hebrew
males. Um, the birth, the early life,
the call of Moses,
the struggle for freedom.
Moses will plead with the Pharaoh to let
his people go and worship their God in
the wilderness. Um, and
then the final liberation.
When God does something at the Red Sea.
We'll talk about that later so
that the Israelites can pass, uh,
leaving the heavy Egyptian Cherry
tree to flounder in the mud.
We have about two and a half
chapters 15 verse 22 til chapter 18.
That recounts then the
journey towards Sinai. Uh,
this is a journey that's filled with
complaints that people complain they're
going to starve and God responds with
quail and Manna and water chapters 19 to
24 very,
very important chapters that contain the
theophanous self revelation of God to
the Israelites and the covenant
that's concluded at Sinai.
We'll be talking more about that next time
versus a chapters 25 to 40,
um,
contained beside the incident. The
unfortunate incident with the golden calf,
which is an exodus 32,
but the rest of this unit from 25 to 40
is God's instructions on how to build or
erect the tabernacle.
And then an account of the Israelites
actually constructing a erecting the
tabernacle source.
Critical scholars believe that Jay
supplies the main narrative of this unit.
In exodus, it's supplemented by
excerpts from [inaudible], from e,
and then the addition of considerable,
um,
legal and ritual and
geological material from p.
Now the historical value of the
exodus story has fascinated scholars,
but also lay people for generations.
Could the exodus really have happened?
And if so, when? And does it matter?
And is there any evidence for the story,
for example,
an external sources outside
the Bible? Well, no,
there isn't any direct evidence
outside the Bible. Well,
let's start at the beginning.
We do have a victory him a victory,
and that's inscribed on a steel
a or a slab of stone, I guess,
which was erected in the year 1204 BCE.
It was erected by a pharaoh,
Pharaoh, Marin, Septa.
So this delay of Moneta dates to
about 1204. And in this victory him,
he's boasting of his victory
over various groups in Canaan.
And one of the groups he claims
to have to feed it is Israel.
Now this is a fabulously
important inscription because
it's the earliest known
reference outside the Bible to any
person or entity that is mentioned in the
Bible.
And it suggests that a people known as
Israel was indeed in the land of Canaan
by the end of the 13th century BCE.
Whether they arrived there after an exodus
from Egypt is not of course indicated
the source doesn't tell us that.
And in fact there's really no
archeological evidence of a group,
a large group entering the
land of Canaan at this time.
There's a steady cultural continuum,
not a not evidence of destruction as
we would expect for a big invasion.
We'll talk more about that when we get
to the book of Joshua, but nevertheless,
let's just go with this for a minute
and if we suppose that it took about a
generation to enter the land. So you
see I've done the math on the side here.
I suppose I should've done subtractions
and since we're talking BCE,
but if we put 20 years in four actually
arriving and settling in the land,
that takes us to about two 20 1225 and
if we assume 40 years of wandering in the
desert or wandering from Egypt,
that takes us to about 1265
as a date for the exodus.
While in 1265 the 18th dynasty sees most
illustrious farrow occupied the throne
Ramses the second who in fact was
pharaoh for 70 years or something,
most of the 13th century, and he is
very famous for his building projects.
Now,
according to the biblical record,
the Hebrews were set to work on urban
building projects in the Delta region
where the Nile at the
north part of the Nile,
the Delta region of the Nile in the
cities of [inaudible] and Ramses.
The Bible states that Israel
was in Egypt for 430 years.
So if we had that, then that would
put her descent into Egypt. Joseph,
the other sons of Jacob around the year
1700 while there's a certain appeal to
that scenario,
because in the 1720s Egypt was invaded
and conquered by a Semitic people known
as the HIG sauce. They established
a dynasty of Semitic rulers.
They were centered in the north of Egypt,
in the area known as Goshen.
So it's possible that the pharaohs of
the Hicks Sauce Dynasty might've favored
other Semites.
They might have allowed them to enter
in times of famine and to dwell in the
land of Goshen,
which the Bible says the Israelites lived
in the land of Goshen so that Joseph
was submitted. Foreigner could
be elevated to an important post.
The post of governor is a little less
surprising if we suppose there was a
Semitic regime in the 16th century.
The native Egyptians who were smarting
and smoldering under the humiliating
foreign rule of the Hicks sows finally
succeeded in rising up and driving them
out and reestablishing a
native Egyptian dynasty.
So some spa scholars have speculated that
that's the historic reality behind the
statement.
In exodus one verse 18 that a new Pharaoh
who knew nothing of Joseph and what he
had done for Egypt began
to oppress the Hebrews.
The feeling is that the establishment
of a new native Egyptian dynasty might
have led to the enslavement of any
remaining Semites or submitted outsiders.
And that would include of course
the Hebrews. So in all probability,
anyone who was associated with the
hated occupying regime would be treated
poorly. And it all seems to fit well.
There's a problem with this theory.
Uh,
the Bible itself contains
very contradictory statements
regarding the length of
the Israelites stay in Egypt.
So Exodus six versus 16 to 20 says that
the Israelites were there for only four
generations,
maybe 80 years from Levi to Moses.
Levi was a great grandfather of Moses,
so only four generations,
which would mean and arrival in Egypt
a long time after the hicks sauce,
not 430 years.
And we don't even know whether migration
occurred in the hicks sauce periods.
So what we have really
is only a hypothesis,
the 430 years numbers also
something of an ideal number.
It places the exodus 480 years before
Solomon's building of the temple.
480 is a multiple of 12 and the
Bible really likes multiples of 12.
So it is an ideal number.
It's a kind of number that
crops up a lot in biblical is,
which makes it suspect for
other sorts of reasons as well.
So the heck sauce theory is one that
got people very excited for awhile,
but it's really not well supported.
But still,
there's some very interesting
circumstantial evidence
for Semites engaged in
building projects in the 13th century.
However,
and whenever they may
have gotten into Egypt,
we do know archaeologically that the
fortified city of p rodacy very much like
Pete told,
Ramses was rebuilt in the early 13th
century on the site of the old Hicks Sauce
capitol.
There was a capital avarice.
They had moved the capital up to the
delta region. It had fallen into decay.
Now in the 13th century, this is being
rebuilt and that's in the area of Goshen.
So the city was being reoccupied in the
time of the Pharaoh Ramses Ramses the
second in the 13th century.
We do know that Egypt officials allowed
hungry nomads to enter the Delta region
for food. We have records
written records of this. Uh,
we also know that Semitic slaves are
well attested in Egypt at this time,
the end of the 13th century.
We also have records of that.
We know of a people called the
[inaudible] or [inaudible].
They don't seem to be an ethnic group
so much as a marginalized social class,
but some have suggested a
connection with the word Hebrew. Um,
we know that they worked on the
building of the capital city of Ramses.
The second other scholars deny there
would be any connection with Hebrew.
The debates are endless.
Um,
one 13th century Egyptian per pirates
describes Egypt's tight control of her
border areas and another reports,
some Egyptian officials
pursuing some runaway slaves.
Obviously this happened from time
to time escaping into the desert.
The exodus story also contains many
Egyptian elements. The name's Moses,
Aaron Pin Hus.
These are all Egypt.
[inaudible] name's Moses is simply
this part of Ramses tooth.
Moses Ramen sees this is Egyptian
for Bourn of Bourn of the god Ra.
The name Moses is an Egyptian name.
So none of this of course,
corroborates the specific
details of the biblical story.
There's no Egyptian record of the
biblical Moses, no record of plagues,
no record of a defeat of Pharaoh's army.
There is a lot of circumstantial evidence
and some scholars think that that
lends plausibility to a story of
slaves working on building projects.
Who escaped from Egypt at this time,
and if there's any historical basis to
the exodus, then the most plausible time,
the most plausible, plausible backdrop
would be the 13th century BCE.
Some scholars assume there's a historical
memory behind the elaborate and
dramatic story of a
miraculous redemption by God.
Why would you invent it?
Hero,
a national hero who's entirely
Egyptian and has an Egyptian name.
Why would you invent an or
a myth of origins in which
your ancestors are slaves?
Um,
nevertheless,
as I emphasized earlier in the
patriarchal stories, in the end,
we are dealing here,
sacred history.
We're dealing with a highly embellished
and theologically interpreted myth of
origins for a nation.
So much more important than historical
verifiability is the conviction of the
ancient Israelites who received and Ben
are rated these traditions and develop
them and embellish them that God
had, wants, acted on their behalf,
rescuing them from bondage, binding
them to himself in an eternal covenant.
A little bit about the outline of the
story and then we're going to finally have
an introduction between God and Moses,
which will I think bring us back to some
of the conversations we've had at the
beginning of the course.
So let me first say a little bit about
the storyline and some of the themes.
At the beginning of exodus, the
first, uh, six or seven chapters,
according to the texts the
Israelites have multiplied,
they filled the land of Goshen that
had been given to them during Joseph's
tenure of an office. And this new pharaoh
who feared them, he didn't know Joseph.
He feared the foreign
presence. Um, he rose and he
attempted to curb their growth.
He pressed all of the
adult males into slavery.
The tech says harsh labor at mortar
and brick, but the text says,
the more they were oppressed,
the more they increased in spread out.
So Pharaoh resorts to
more drastic measures.
He decrees the murder of all newborn
Israelite males at the hands of Egyptian
midwives. He's forwarded by these
midwives. They say, oh, these,
these ladies are too quick.
We get there too late.
They've already given birth
by the time we arrive.
They allow the male infants to live.
So the Fairlawn lists all of the people
to annihilate the Israelites by drowning
all newborn males in the Nile river.
And this leads then to the account of the
birth of Moses and his exposure to the
Nile River. He's born to a Levite family.
The Levites will be priests in Israel.
So he's born to a priestly family.
He's hidden away for three months and
then he's placed in a wicker basket,
which is lined with bitchumen tar,
um,
and set among the bull rushes
at the edge of the Nile River.
Pharaoh's daughter will
eventually discover him.
His own mother will volunteer to be
his nurse and Pharaoh's daughter will
eventually adopt him and named him
Moses. Again, this is an Egyptian name.
The etymology given in the
biblical text is, is invented.
A lot of scholars have noted
that this story is full of irony.
The rescue of Moses who will foil Pharaoh
is affected by the daughter of that
Pharaoh and Moses grows up in a sheltered
right in the Pharaoh's own palace.
Further, the significance of Moses is
hinted at through literary allusions in,
in the narrative of his,
his birth, his infancy,
the basket in which he has placed is
called an arc. The Hebrew word is Teva.
This word is used precisely
twice in the entire Hebrew Bible.
It's not the same word that's used
for Ark of the covenant. By the way,
the Ark of the covenant, the word
is our own. This word for arc,
Teva occurs exactly twice here and
in the story of Noah's Ark. Okay.
Noah's Ark a Teva and scholars have always
been quick to point out that in both
cases, this, this arc, this Teva,
is in the words of one scholar,
the instrument of salvation
through perilous waters,
waters that threatened to capsize it.
And so blot out God's hopes
and plans for his creatures.
Moreover,
the basket is placed among the reeds,
but the Hebrew word for reeds safe.
And that's a hand or an illusion to the
fact that Moses will lead the Israelites
through the Reed Sea. The yum soup. It's
not the Red Sea, it's the reeds. See,
but we'll talk about that
later also. But legendary. Uh,
this legendary birth story has important
parallels in ancient near eastern and
other literature.
It's very common to find stories of the
extraordinary events that surround the
birth of someone who will later become
great Cyrus of Persia eat us Jesus.
So on.
Many scholars have pointed out that this
story in particular is paralleled by
the birth story of a great Acadian King
Sargon from about 2100 BCE Sargon of
ICAD,
strikingly similar story to Moses placed
in a basket line with tar putting the
river and so on and underscores the
degree to which this story is part of a
literary genre,
part of the literary convention,
how much the exodus story itself
is very much a literary story.
Nothing is said of Moses,
his childhood,
but we learn of his awareness of his
Israelite identity or as identification
with the Hebrews in the following passage.
This is an exodus two verses 11 to 15
some time after that when Moses had grown
up, he went out to his kinsfolk
and witnessed their labors.
He saw an Egyptian beating,
a Hebrew, one of his kinsman.
He turned this way in that
and seeing no one about,
he struck down the Egyptian
and hit him in the sand.
When he went out the next day he found
two Hebrews fighting and so he said to
the offender, why do you strike your
fellow? He retorted, homemade you,
chief and ruler over us.
Do you mean to kill me?
As you killed that Egyptian Moses was
frightened and thought than the matter is
known and when Pharaoh learned of
the matter, he sought to kill Moses,
but Moses fled from Pharaoh.
He arrived in the land of Midian
and sat down beside a well.
So coming to the aid of
an oppressed kinsmen,
Moses kills an Egyptian and he has to
flee to the territory of Midian and
they're at the whale again.
He acts to defend the defenseless.
This is a key to his character.
These two episodes are the two
that were given of Moses, his life.
So continuing verses 16
and 17 in exodus to now,
the priest of Midian had seven daughters.
They came to draw water and fill,
filled the troughs to
water their father's flock.
But shepherds came and drove them off.
Moses rose to their defense and
he watered their flock. So again,
it's a key to Moses,
his character aiding the defenseless.
Moses will later Mary's Apora one of
these women and lives as a shepherd in
Midian for about 40 years now,
the situation of the Israelites in Egypt,
the text says remains bitter.
Exodus two 23 to 24,
the Israelites were groaning under the
bondage and cried out and their cry for
help from the bondage rose up to God.
God heard their moaning and God remembered
his covenant with Abraham and Isaac
and Jacob One day in the
wilderness at a place called Horeb,
also Sinai, where there's a mountain. Uh,
Moses sees a flame in a Bush
that doesn't consume the flame,
and then he hears a voice and the voice
says, I am the god of your father,
the god of Abraham, the god of
Isaac, and the God of Jacob.
And Moses hides his face and fear, but
God continues. He has a job for Moses.
I have marked well the plight of my people
in Egypt and have heeded their outcry
because of the task master.
Yes,
I am mindful of their sufferings and
I've come down to rescue them from the
Egyptians and to bring them out of
that land to a good and spacious land,
a land flowing with milk and honey, the
region of the Canaanites, the Hittites,
the Amorites, the parasites,
he invites and the Jebusites.
Now the cry of the Israelites
has reached me. Moreover,
I have seen how the Egyptians
oppress them. Come. Therefore,
I will send you to Pharaoh
and you shall free my people.
The Israelites from Egypt.
It's exodus three verses seven to 10
and Moses Dumb Yours, right? Who? Me?
Why not my big brother Aaron?
He's a much better public speaker.
So the line that he takes,
I'm slow of tongue,
but as we've already seen in genesis,
God chooses who he chooses and
his reasons aren't always fathoms.
Moses says,
may I say who sent me?
He asks for God's name. The Israelites
would want to know who has sent me.
And God replies with a sentence.
He Gay. I share. Hey, Yay.
This is the first part, second sentence
that can be translated. I am who I am,
or perhaps I will be who I will be or
perhaps I cause to be what I cause to be.
We really don't know,
but it has something to do with being so.
We asked who god is.
God says,
I am who I am or I will cause
to be what I will cause to be.
So Moses wisely enough converts that
into a third person formula. Okay.
He will be who he will be. He is who he
is. Yeah. Wait, I share. Yeah. Hawaii.
God's answer to the question of his
name is with this sentence and Moses
converts it from a first person
to third person sentence.
He will be who he will be. He is
who he is. He will cause to be.
I think most people think now what he
will cause to be and that sentence gets
shortened to [inaudible]. This is the
Bible's explanation for the name. Yeah,
way and as the personal name of God.
Some have argued that the name halfway
expresses the quality of being an active
dynamic. Being this God is one
who brings things into being,
whether it's a cosmos from chaos or
now new nation from a band of runaway
slaves.
But it could well be that this is simply
God's way of not answering most of his
question.
We've seen how the Bible feels about
revealing names and the divine being who
struggled and wrestled with Jacob,
sure didn't want to give him his name.
So I've often wondered if were to
read this differently. Who am I?
I am who I am and never you mind.
But there are certain important and
unique features of this burning Bush
dialogue. First, God identifies
himself to Moses as the god of Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob. And as
numerous commentators have
pointed out, in so doing,
the biblical writer is trying to
establish an unbroken historic continuity
between the president,
revelation to Moses and the revelations
and promises that are received by
Israel's forefathers,
the Patriarchs.
And yet paradoxically,
the various [inaudible] of continuity
only serves to underscore a fundamental
discontinuity. Because even as God asserts
that he is the God of the Patriarchs,
he reveals to Moses a new name.
Yeah. Halfway. So that, yeah,
wisdom and the hallway called can
be said to begin only with Moses.
Now as we've seen,
the biblical sources differ on this point.
According to the j source in genesis
four 26 the earliest humans worshiped
Galloway Sci way.
The name was always known.
Jay wants to assert a direct continuity
between the God of the Patriarchs and
the god of the exodus,
the P and e sources.
Tell it a little differently.
Exit a six verses two to
four very important passage.
Exodus six verses two to four.
It's assigned to p and here God says,
I am [inaudible]. I
appeared to Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob as El Shaddai,
but I did not make myself known
to them by my name. Yeah. Halfway.
Now this contradicts the j source
and many scholars have suggested
that p and e preserve a memory of a
time when Israel worshiped the Canaanite
God,
l p and a wish to claim that the God who
covenanted with the Patriarchs is the
god of the exodus. But now with
a new name. They also liked j.
They want to assert a continuity.
But in doing so,
they do it in a way that really ultimately
draws attention to the fundamental
discontinuity, the sense
of a new beginning. And to
understand that new beginning,
we need to look at the differences
between patriarchal religion and the new,
yeah. Wisdom. And there's
a list on your handout.
So I hope everyone got a copy
of the handout. If you didn't,
perhaps you can raise your hand.
And if the tfs have any left,
you'll want to take a look at these
differences between patriarchal religion,
mosaic. Yeah. Was the miss
this, this is going to help us.
This list is based on information that's
supplied by you, by many scholars. Um,
I relied very much on Michael Coogan,
but others as well.
Look, first at the sheet that gives
you the titles, the titles of God,
and you'll see that in the
patriarchal traditions. All right,
so we're talking about genesis primarily.
I've thrown in some other texts also,
but, but focusing for a moment on the
patriarchal traditions of Genesis,
God is six times called El Shaddai.
Other names are El El Young, El
[inaudible], El [inaudible], El Beth El.
You can see the translations of these,
the everlasting God, God most high,
and God is seeing the god of
the House of God and so on.
L is the name of the chief
God in the Canaanite Pantheon.
Flip over to the other
side of your handout
where I discuss an important set of texts
that were discovered at a place called
Russ Shamara.
Rochelle was ancient Uga street.
In 1928 a peasant in Syria
discovered a tomb at rush shamrock,
which was subsequently
excavated by the French,
and it was found to contain a library of
tablets that were written in a language
very,
very close to biblical Hebrew.
It's clear that Hebrew was simply
a Canaanite dialect. In fact,
I remember reading, one scholar
said, if you go back far enough,
you're really hard pressed to tell the
difference between Canaanite and a Hebrew.
And in these texts we read of the exploits
of the gods of Canaanite religion.
These gods include the sky
God l I've listed here,
uh, the father of the various
gods and humans. L has a wife.
I shared raw. She's listed third
on your paper, a mother goddess,
their daughter, and not to as a goddess
of love and war. She's quite fierce.
And then their son bow,
who is a storm. God.
He's depicted in mythological literature
as defeating both the chaotic,
see God to see God,
Yum and the god of death.
Mote there are striking resemblances
between the biblical God of the Patriarchs
and the Canaanite God.
L L is the head of the council of Gods.
He has said to have a long white beard.
He dwells on a mountain top in a tent.
His epithets include father
of all creatures, Bull King.
He is also described as the protector
of Patriarchs. Patriarchal figures,
eight God of the father of the clan.
It says in the text, he guides them.
You protects them.
He promises them descendants.
Many biblical passages depict God exactly
this way as the head of a council of
divine beings.
He's occasionally described with some of
the epithets that are associated with l
is referred to as the
father of all creatures.
There are poetic passages in which
he is referred to as bull. Also,
certainly as king and in
the patriarchal narratives.
God refers to himself as the god of
the father. I am the god of the father,
the same way El Reef is referred to.
He Guides and protects the Patriarchs.
He makes promises of progeny
to Abraham and his heirs. Um,
he also is associated with a mountain
top Sinai and gives instructions for the
building of a tabernacle,
a tent like structure in which he will
dwell many personal and place names in
the patriarchal narratives are
compounds in which one element is l use,
right? Hell, you Schmidt,
l l l is the God of the Patriarchs.
By contrast,
after the time of Moses,
Israelite names start
to be formed using yeah,
or Yahoo as part of the name Yahweh,
Alijah and Hebrews Eliyahu.
So you start to have Thea forex names
that use a name of a deity which are using
forms of Yahoo instead of l.
There are other descriptions
in the Bible of God,
which are much more reminiscent however
of the storm God Baal according to
Canaanite mythology by I'll defeated l
and assumed his position at a certain
point as the head of
the Canaanite Pantheon.
So there was a switch and
Canaanite mythology from l
two to bow becoming supreme
like bow. Yeah, wait,
is said to ride on the clouds of a
poetic passage in which that's the case.
His revelations are accompanied
by thunder storms. Earthquakes,
by all is a god of the storm.
There are poetic fragments also that
allude to you always victory over watery
foes. And that is a motif
that's associated with,
by all who does battle with the yum,
with the C.
And finally also associated
with Israel's God.
We have ancient near eastern
holy war traditions. Um,
God is depicted as a
warrior who leads his host,
the Lord of hosts in battle. He's armed
with spear and, and bow and arrows,
the worship practices of ancient Israel.
And Judah clearly resemble what we know
of Canaanite and ancient near eastern
worship practices.
Canaanite religious ritual took places,
small temples that housed cultic,
a cultic statues.
There were stone pillars.
Perhaps the symbols of the
gods are memorials to the dead.
There were altars for animal
sacrifices, cereal, liquid sacrifices.
Similarly,
Israel's gods or Israel's God was
worshiped at various high places.
They're referred to as
elevated or high places.
These were shrines with little altars,
maybe cultic pillars and wooden poles.
The word for a wooden pole that's
used in the Bible is I Shay Ra.
These shrines may have been associated
with some kind of contact with ancestors.
Um,
some kind of cult of the dead.
Now worship at these local altars and
high places will come to be banned.
Deuteronomy is going to
polemicizing against this.
Deuteronomy will insist that all worship
must occur in one central sanctuary and
these outlying areas and they're
Ashley wrote, are to be destroyed.
It will just decree the destruction
of all of these altars in high places.
The patriarchal stories are clearly
not the work of the deuteronomist.
And these stories must have had very long
standing traditional authority if they
were adopted without serious modification
by the deuteronomist redact or some
modification, but not serious.
So what is going on here?
What are we to make of the incredible
similarity of Israel's deity and cult to
those of her neighbors?
How are we to understand the rise
of Israel's God, Israel's religion?
Well, so far we've had two models
that have been thrown out to you.
I'm the kind of classic evolutionary
model from polytheism is worship of many
gods. There's a natural evolution to
henotheism his denial of all gods,
but I'm sorry,
the elevation of one God to a supreme
position sort of one comes to be favored
and then eventually becomes so important
to the others, really fall away.
And you have really
the denial of all gods.
But the one we saw Koufman in
the 1930s reacted against this.
He argued that monotheism and polytheism
are so radically distinct that one
could not possibly have
evolved from the other.
Surely there's an element
of truth in both models.
The evolutionary model is
I think responding to and
picking up on the fact that
in many respects, yeah, wait, resembles
the gods of Israel's neighbors.
To Be Blunt, the Patriarchs seem
to have worship the Canaanite God l
the problem with the evolutionary model
is that it doesn't account for those
aspects of the biblical texts that show
a clear political relationship between
Israel's religion and
that if her neighbors,
we saw when we read genesis one that
there was something going on there.
There's a polemic going on.
All right?
There are straight up within the Bible
that are clearly polemicizing against,
um, certain kind of mythological
presentation of the deity.
By contrast,
Kaufman's revolutionary model pharmacists
focuses almost exclusively on the
dissimilarities and the polemic over
relationship between your wisdom and
Canaanite polytheism.
So the revolutionary model also fails
because it doesn't acknowledge the many,
many areas of contact,
similarity, and even identity.
So a third way has emerged in the
last 20 years or 15 years or so,
and it's one that seeks to avoid
this dichotomy between polytheism and
monotheism.
Instead of viewing Israelite religion as
an evolution from and a refinement just
as natural process of refinement of
Canaanite religion or as a radical break
with and polemic against
Canaanite religion,
you have some biblical smart scholars.
Mark Smith is among them. Stephen Geller,
who,
um,
examine the cultural and ideological
negotiations that gave rise to Israelite
monotheism.
What do I mean?
Mark Smith specifically describes the
origin and development of Israelite
religion as a process of what he
calls convergence and differentiation.
He writes,
convergence involve the coalescence of
various deities and or some of their
features into the figure of Yahweh.
There is a period of convergence
and blending of the deities.
By contrast,
he describes differentiation as a process
whereby Israel came to reject it's
Canaanite roots and create
a separate identity.
At some point there was a desire to
separate and in that process of identity
formation, a polemic began to
develop that created um, uh,
y'all way in a distinct
way, didn't differentiate it
from the Canaanite deities.
So let's consider Smith's convergence.
First.
The Canaanite roots of
Israel's ancestors are clear.
The Hebrew language itself is
essentially Canaanite, Canaanite dialect,
the Canaanite, Canaanite God
l was from the Biblical text,
the God of Israel's earliest ancestors.
Through a process of convergence,
he argues the god,
Yahweh,
the God that we think originally came
from a region further South Sinai,
you dome somewhere further south.
But this God through a
process of convergence and
cultural mixing began to take
on the characteristics of other deities,
first l and then bow or sort of
simultaneously l and bow later.
Certain aspects of this convergence would
be polemicizing against and rejected
as a yacht way only party sought to
differentiate itself from those that it
would now label as other and call
Canaanites as distinct from Israelites.
Smith's model of convergence.
And then differentiation
has great explanatory power.
It explains the deep similarity
of Israel's Dd and the
deities of her neighbors,
but it also explains the vehement biblical
polemic against Canaanite religion
and Baal worship in particular,
which we will come to see.
It reminds one of sibling
rivalry, right? Um,
siblings who obviously share a tremendous
amount and can be extraordinarily
similar, are precisely the siblings who
can struggle and wrestle the most to
differentiate themselves from one another.
Smith's model of convergence and
differentiation also avoids unhelpful
dichotomies. Israel is either
like or unlike her neighbors,
right.
That's not helpful.
It helps us to understand Israel's God
as the end product of familiar cultural
processes,
the processes of convergence and we see
convergences of cultures all the time
and differentiation, differentiations
of culture happen all the time as well.
When and why,
you may ask did this differentiation
occur when and why did some Israelites
adopt a yacht way only position and seek
to differentiate what they would call a
pure Yoffe wisdom from the cult of bottle?
For example,
the debate over that question is fierce
and it's one we're going to leave for
another day.
We will come back as we continue moving
through the biblical text and we will
address that question,
but to sum up,
it's clear that the biblical patriarchs
and matriarchs or not strict yeah.
With says we will come
to understand that term.
The p and the east sources
depict a preserve the insight.
They preserve this insight and they
preserve it in their insistence that the
Patriarchs worshiped God as l.
But at the time of the exodus,
God revealed himself as he halfway.
It's an interesting passage in the book
of Joshua Joshua 24 verses 14 to 15
Joshua who's the successor to Moses,
he presents the Israelites
with the following choice.
Now therefore revere the
Lord using the word Yahweh,
revere Yaffe Way and serve
him with undivided loyalty.
Put away the gods that your forefathers
served beyond the Euphrates and in Egypt,
put away the gods your forefathers served
beyond the Euphrates and in Egypt and
serve Yahweh. Choose this day
which ones you are going to serve,
but I in my household
will serve you halfway.
Serves the Lord only later what a Galloway
only party polemicizing against and
seek to suppress certain what came
to be seen as undesirable elements of
Israelite Judy and religion.
And these elements would be labeled
Canaanite as a part of a process of
Israelite differentiation.
But what appears in the Bible
as a battle between Israelites,
periodicity,
and Canaanites pure polytheists is
indeed better understood as a civil war
between Yahweh way only Israelites and
Israelites who were participating in the
color of their ancestors.